An unknown hero leaps into action,...
...scaling a Paris apartment building to save a child...
...dangling from a balcony five stories up,...
...his heroic feat caught on camera.
The secret identity of this amazing Spiderman?
Mamoudou Gassama, 22 years old, an illegal immigrant from Mali.
Illegal no more.
The French President invited Gassama to the Elysee palace this morning...
...to thank him for his bravery  and offer him French citizenship.
Thanks to him, a four-year-old boy is safe.
French authorities say the boy's father had gone off to the grocery store...
...and then got distracted playing Pokemon Go.
He'll now face criminal charges of child neglect.
But Gassama's citizenship isn't the only reward.
He's also been offered a job as a firefighter...
...so he can practice every day the heroism he showed in that daring rescue.
David Wright, ABC News, New York.